sweet Mary Jane is my vice your boys on
the other hand is and always has been a
destroyer of world around a touch and I
would like you to consider in our fun I
am not for sale
how is this a different kind of
experience yeah I mean that's exactly
right I mean I want that's what struck
me when I wrote read the script
originally was that it was like a return
to vintage Guy Ritchie you know and I
was so excited to get to work with him
the first time when King Arthur but you
know it was sort of outside the
sensibility of the context of what I'd
gotten me so excited about guy in the
first place and the beginning of my
career where I sort of started acting
and thought you know maybe one day in
the future I get to work with him so
when he sent me this script it sort of
was like the fulfillment of a real wish
that I've had for many years what do you
play in the film I play um the
right-hand man of Matthew McConaughey's
character who basically is this dude who
is basically the top boy in the UK
marijuana business and I play what on
the surface what appears to be quite a
administrative logistical organized you
know quite bookish guy and then as the
film goes on I reveal that there's a
much darker side to the my function in
the organization how is this different
from anything you've done before so I
play character I play character cool dry
eye he's a young couth very hungry
gangster who's who's vying for for a
math McConaughey's sort of business an
industry and so he's cut through he's
unpredictable and
it's pretty much the polar opposite so
anything that everybody sort of seen me
in so far so it's it was a joy you know
we're at CinemaCon it's all about
promoting upcoming movies what's like a
movie that's upcoming that you're
excited about kind of geeking out about
see oh my gosh
I think obviously endgame I mean
Chadwicks on the wreck top Dave's over
there and I think it's we've contr stage
where it's become a part of our lives
it's like wait for the the big Avengers
movie or the big Marvel blockbuster and
we've been strung along this route to
have the conclusion like a DA fingertips
like I can't wait for that you want to
do one of those movies who knows who
knows Marvel's I mean Marvel DC there's
so many amazing characters that these
phenomenal writers created hopefully
there's one in there for me who knows
you